You'll learn as you're going and get older,
you make your own shortcut.
You’ll always make it back home.
Ready, Glyn?
Oh, yeah.
Glyn and I are off to pull out
crab pots from Olga Bay, where he has one
And I have one.
And that increases our chances of getting crab.
When we pull the crab pots it's a long way, about thirty-forty minutes skiff ride
Out here on the open water, the weather is not always in our favor because of the swell that washes right up.
The crab pots we’re
gonna pull are in a bay
and it’s
a lot calmer and a lot easier to get.
We got to get everything
before the winter hits.
Otherwise,
it's pretty hard to get up there.
You get some wicked
winds with tide flowing in and out.
Driving around out
here is like studying for a test.
You got to memorize
where all the rocks are, any reefs.
It's woo!
Where is my buoy?
It should be right here.
You should see the buoy
no matter how many whitecaps there are.
It’s a big orange buoy.
It’s just like my Uncle Marvin’s gear
he has on.
Mine should be real close around here.
It’s just that small cork
is very hard to see.
If we find Glyn’s, I got a good bearing
of where my crab pot is.
I don't see mine anywhere
Is that the cork right there Glyn?
Is that a cork?
I think that’s your cork.
We’re not finding Glyn’s crab pot,
decreases the chance by half
because not all the pulls we do
are successful king crab.
Oh, you got that pipe out already,
okay. I got you.
Our chances now are cut in half
by one pot missing and hope we get something in this.
There we go.
Coming up, Glyn.
You could stop it.
So, how’d we do?
Whoa, look at that.
Scored heavy.
Like we scored, we are not going home
empty handed.
There you go.
Lot of females.
So, I think we got a couple keepers
but there’s so much females, I’m
very happy to see that.
Flip it over?
Yeah.
Oh, so happy to see females
because I know that at least there’s
some there to reproduce
and that's a very good sign.
This is a female Glyn.
See how the female round belly? Big
Big belly.
Oh is that the eggs right there?
You see them in there?
Oh yeah. Yeah.
There's a lot eggs.
Females.
It's the future.
If there's anything that we want
is crab for the future.
There’s a male to keep, how big he is.
Keep her here? Yeah.
All right.
I lost my pot but, I’m bringing food home.
Good stuff, Glyn.
Well worth the trip,
even with half the crab pots.
Found one crab pot,
what's missing is my big orange
buoy.